hey guys cysteine and today I am going
to be showing you guys something that
has been out for a long time and I have
absolutely no idea why I've never bought
this before if you're new here I'm only
losing my keys I'm always losing my
dongle I'm always losing something and
there's a solution for that
it's a solution that has been around for
a while my friend Edie is obsessed with
these tiles I finally broke down and
realized that I had a problem and when
you have a problem and you know that you
have a problem and you admit to yourself
you have won the first step you need to
take action and my action was like any
tile I once lost my wallet for so long
but I knew it was in my help I couldn't
find it I knew it was here so I wasn't
that concerned that it was out in the
wild and nobody was using my credit card
so I was safe the problem I had to find
it this is a while ago but recently I
lost my wallet again I was like oh this
can't keep happening
so with these guys you basically can
attach them to things here it is like
this one I can just attach my key ring
now this one's a little bit bigger
so this one I'm probably going to throw
in my luggage I'll grow this one in my
wallet it's nice and slim so it's a
balance in the width of two credit cards
so they just connect to an iPhone apps
also have the ability to ping them
they'll make it noise so if your item
that you're looking for is in your house
you'll be able to hear it why did I not
get this sooner and now I only have 4
what am I going to do like I'm a bot one
oh my god he's one second for one
computer I'm gonna put on my dog home
and make it one of Jetta so I can do
where she is so first at first is I need
to download the tile app so I'm gonna be
traveling to what I want to do is I want
to be able to test this out to see if I
put it in my luggage and while actually
I'm not checking my bag so that's not
going to work but in theory I'll be able
to know when my luggage is sort of
getting close to me because it will
connect to my phone and what's cool is
if you happen to lose said I am so to
say I lose my drone and I decide to put
this on my drone if somebody else who
I'm using tile is within reach of my
tile it will be able to ping their phone
they won't know that they're being
pinged
but because they
pained I'm then seemed to know that my
item is someone because these don't have
GPS built into it but because the tile
community is so large and like a last
person to join the party the more people
that have tiles of more connected they
become so what is required location
requires iPhone battery savings optional
I don't know okay
looks good to me find your tile walk
around and until the circle turns green
then ring your child so you do have to
be close enough but you can basically
kind of walk around your house to try to
find your items and when it turns green
but the child logo wants to begin it
will play a nice tune it's activating
its activating it fascinating so this
one I'm going to be putting in my wallet
fine let's activate these last two all
this is so great it shocks me every time
cool well I'm going to need to get a
couple more I want to get on my camera
the number one thing is these are great
this is great this is not sponsored this
is I bought these like the description
if you guys want to check these out I
promise you if this might be the coolest
thing that I've seen in a really long
time actually bleh my dad because he
asked me what I thought of them and I
was like you know ed thinks they're
really cool and he uses them a lot I
should probably check it out and after a
lot as well as the other day is like our
guy this is I think now is the time that
I need to just I need to tile it up
tiled it I'll see you guys in the video
I'm going to go put these with a ball
[Music]
varmint so um a few songs trying to kill
yourself or your friends leave you
power-ups drop more